das wäre der durchbruch für elektroautos
tesla plant einen neuen akku der nicht
nur extrem langlebig sondern auch noch
deutlich billiger als seine vorgänger
sein soll
damit könnten elektroautos endlich so
günstig wie verbrenner hergestellt
werden
die weiterentwicklung der lithium ionen
technologie durch test soll jetzt völlig
neue maßstäbe setzen die laufzeit des
akkus und wie schneller auf den markt
kommen soll ist unglaublich genau wie
der gigantische maßstab in dem er
produziert werden soll pixum science im
future hier gibt es regelmäßig umfassend
recherchiert des seins videos in denen
es um wissenschaft und unsere zukunft
geht abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen es ändert
sich etwas ab sofort heißt dieser kanal
clixoom science and future es geht um
die zukunft der menschheit und da werden
wissenschaft und ihre unverzichtbare
bedeutung für unsere zukunft immer
wichtiger
ich sammle hier unsere kräfte und auch
die videos aus unserem nature kanal gibt
es deshalb hier mit dem schwerpunkt
wissenschaft und unsere zukunft das
ganze wurde mir beim schreiben meines
buches bewusst per aufzug in den
weltraum der unterschied zwischen
science und fiction das im herbst
erscheint es geht um unsere zukunft und
für die und damit für die wissenschaft
treten wir hier ein und damit sind wir
direkt beim thema beim kampf um die
spitzenposition unter den
elektroautohersteller geht es vor allem
um eins die akkutechnologie denn statt
kraftstoff wie in dieselfahrzeugen und
benzinern sind die akkumulatoren kurz
akkus und die darin gespeicherte energie
die energiequelle die den autos
überhaupt die fortbewegung ermöglichen
deshalb sind sie der entscheidende
erfolgsfaktor der hersteller denn das
akku bestimmt die reichweite also wie
weit man fahren kann ohne einen
tankstopp einlegen zu müssen außerdem
ist die ladezeit entscheiden also wie
lange es dauert um ein akku wieder
aufzuladen schließlich geht es um die
lebensdauer der autos die je nach abo
unterschiedlich ausfallen kann
in den letzten jahren hört man immer
wieder von neuen durchbrechen und so
genannten super akkus die die
elektromobilität vorantreiben sollen
jetzt machte samsung schlagzeilen mit
einem akku das elektro reichweiten von
bis zu 800 kilometern ermöglichen sollte
und dessen prototyp eine lebensdauer von
mehr
1000 ladezyklen haben soll das heißt
dass man ein akku tausend mal aufladen
kann bevor es deutlich an kapazität
verliert also immer weniger energie
darin gespeichert werden kann auch tesla
soll jetzt ein mega durchbruch gelungen
sein
eine so günstige und langlebige batterie
mit der e autos endlich den sprung in
die preisklasse von verbrennern schaffen
können die neue batterie soll zusammen
mit einem chinesischen konzern
entwickelt worden seien für die
realisierung hatte tesla chef elon musk
extra ein expertenteam für akkus
angeheuert damit die elektroautos
preislich mit verbrenner mithalten
können verzichtet tesla in der neuen
super batterie weitgehend auf den
einsatz teurer materialien wie kobalt
zusätzlich werden komponenten eingesetzt
die für eine längere laufzeit und
lebensdauer der akkus sorgen in einem
kürzlich angemeldeten patenten ging es
um eine neue akku technologie bei der
die sogenannten tabs die fahnen die an
den anoden und kathoden von
batteriezellen also dem plus und
minuspol angebracht sind entfernt werden
sollen dadurch soll die produktion
kostengünstiger und die lebensdauer
sowie ladefähigkeit erhöht werden die
technologie basiert auf der von
lithium-ionen-akkus die funktioniert so
ein solcher akku besteht aus vielen
kleinen batterien aus den batteriezellen
in diesen zellen gelangt der strom durch
elektrisch leitfähige schichten wie
aluminium oder kupfer dazwischen sind
eine positive und eine negative
elektrode die kathode und die anode die
kathode ist der pluspol der batterie und
die anode der minuspol die ladungsträger
der batterie sind die lithium ionen von
ion spricht man wenn ein atom oder
molekül nicht im neutralen zustand ist
in dem es genauso viele elektronen wie
protonen hat wenn es also mehr oder
weniger elektronen als proton hat hat es
da durch eine elektrische ladung und
wird als die jungen bezeichnet ionen mit
einem elektronen überschuss sind negativ
geladene ionen mit weniger elektronen
sind positiv geladene ionen auf lithium
basis wandern in der zelle durch ein
transportmedium das leitfähige
elektrolyt wenn die batterie aufgeladen
wird wandern die positiv geladenen
lithium ionen durch das elektrolyt von
der katholisch zur anode und lagern sich
dort ein
die batterie ist danach geladen beim
entladen der batterie wandern die
lithium ion zurück
in die kathode dadurch wird elektrische
energie frei die dann zum beispiel im
motor eines autos in mechanische energie
umgewandelt werden kann dadurch dass
anode und kathode in einer batteriezelle
gerollt werden entstehen riesige flächen
und dadurch dass tausende solcher zellen
in einem akku pack enthalten sind können
dementsprechend auch riesige
energiemengen gespeichert werden damit
das überhaupt funktioniert hat tesla ein
ausgeklügeltes batteriemanagementsystem
entwickelt das die akkus im optimalen
temperaturbereich hält und vor
überhitzung schützt die akkus können
viel energie auf kleinem raum speichern
sind vergleichsweise sicher schnell
wieder aufgeladen und noch dazu relativ
günstig herstellbar
durch ihr konstruktionsprinzip sind sie
im vergleich zu anderen batterien auch
lange haltbar denn bei lithium ionen
speichern fließen geladene lithium ionen
zwischen den beiden elektroden hin und
her ohne dass dabei ein bauteil
verschleiß den anderen batterien
verbrauchen sich die elektroden durch
chemische reaktionen bei jedem lade und
entladevorgang ein bisschen mehr und die
speicherleistung lässt schnell nach
durch diese eigenschaften haben die
lithium ionen akkumulatoren unser leben
revolutioniert und ein sozusagen
kabelloses leben mit elektronischen
geräten ermöglicht sie sind inzwischen
überall in smartphones akkuschraubern
die dadurch inzwischen zu akku
bohrmaschine geworden sind
elektrofahrrädern computer uhren und so
weiter und so fort dafür gab es im
letzten jahr sogar den chemie-nobelpreis
der ging an gleich drei preisträger die
gleichermaßen zur entwicklung der
technologie beigetragen haben die heute
aus unserem alltag gar nicht mehr
wegzudenken ist an den amerikaner john
good enough der übrigens in jena geboren
wurde und mit 97 jahren der älteste
preisträger ist den es je gab und zwar
der immer noch an akkus forsch und zwar
jetzt an festkörper akkus und an dem
britisch amerikanischen chemiker stanley
whiting mund an akira hoshino aus japan
die begründung für die auszeichnung ist
die bedeutung der technologie für die
zukunft die akkus ebnen den weg für eine
welt ohne fossile kraftstoffe
die lithium ionen batterien haben
überhaupt erst möglich gemacht e-autos
mit relevante reichweite zu entwickeln
außerdem können sie große mengen an
solar- und windenergie speichern und
machen damit den einsatz erneuerbarer
energie
im großen maßstab möglich begonnen hat
alles in den 1970 er jahren während der
damaligen ölkrise entwickelte der
britische chemiker stanley whiting ham
ein entscheidendes bauteil für
lithium-ionen-batterien ersetzte titan
sulfid als neuartiges material als
kathode ein über die die elektronen
wandern wo durch strom fließt es ist aus
atom schichten aufgebaut zwischen denen
sich das silizium einlagern kann indem
die einzelnen teilchen voneinander
getrennt sind sind sie kontrollierbar
geworben der lithium ist eines der
reaktiv ssten elemente überhaupt es
kommt in der natur nicht mehr in seiner
ursprünglichen metallischen form vor
weil es mit wasser sauerstoff und
anderen substanzen reagiert nimmt man
zum beispiel ein stück lithium und wirft
es ins wasser schwimmt es zwischen auf
der wasseroberfläche hin und her weil
wasserstoff entsteht der sich selbst
entzünden kann diese reaktivität in den
griff zu bekommen bereitete den weg für
den durchbruch der technologie john
goodwin 8 entwickelt in diesen ansatz in
den 80er jahren weiter und fand an
kartenmaterial das noch besser war aber
den gleichen schichtaufbau hat lithium
kobalt oxid damit konnte er die
energiedichte in der batterie erhöhen
auf basis von good enough château de
entwickelte akira hoshino die akkus
weiter und setzte in der anode
petrolkoks statt dem reaktionsfreudige
lithium ein dieses kohlenstoff material
kann wie das kobalt oxid der kathode
lithium ionen aufnehmen dadurch schufa
den ersten leichten sicheren und
gebrauchsfähigen lithium ionen akku der
sich hunderte male aufladen ließ bevor
ein leistungsverlust eintrat die
lithium-ionen-technologie eroberte
erstmals den markt seitdem wurde die
technologie stetig weiterentwickelt und
optimiert in 25 jahren konnte die
energiedichte der akkus um den faktor 4
gesteigert werden doch so langsam kommen
die akkus physikalisch an ihre grenzen
das wurde schon deutlich als samsung vor
ein paar jahren die energiedichte noch
weiter erhöht und die akkus verkleinern
wollte die akkus überhitzen und manche
smartphones fing sogar feuer
neben der leistungsfähigkeit und
sicherheit der akkus rückt auch das
thema nachhaltigkeit immer mehr in den
vordergrund die forschung sucht nach
anderen materialien die nicht wie kobalt
unter unzumutbaren bedingungen
gebaut werden auch die verbesserung der
recyclingfähigkeit rückt in den
vordergrund deshalb werden akkus
heutzutage oft mit einem kleineren
anteil an kuba produzieren und
stattdessen werden in der kathode unter
anderem nickel mangan oder aluminium
zugemischt auch tesla setzt bei seiner
neuen super batterie auf weniger kobalt
außerdem soll der neue akku eine
deutlich höhere energiedichte haben und
die ist letztlich entscheidend davon
hängt ab wie weit ein elektroauto ohne
einen tankstopp kommt die kleinsten
modelle schaffen aktuell um die 150
kilometer reichweite
hochpreisige autos schaffen über 400
oder wie der platzhirsch das tesla model
s ganze 610 kilometer weit die meist
niedrigere reichweite als bei
verbrennern kommt daher dass die
energiedichte von akkus geringer ist als
die vom benzin in einem kilogramm benzin
das sind rund 1,33 liter stecken fast
12.000 wattstunden energie die zum ionen
batterien autos kommen nur auf eine
energiedichte von maximal 150 watt
stunden pro kilogramm
ja das ist fast 100 wenn ein
durchschnittliches elektroauto auf 100
kilometer ungefähr 20.000 stunden
verbraucht braucht es dafür schon 150
kilogramm an akkus teslas neue akkus
ermöglichen jetzt höhere
speicherkapazitäten in den fahrzeugen
batterien bei gleichen bauraum außerdem
spielt natürlich der preis eine wichtige
rolle denn nach wie vor sind
elektroautos deutlich teurer als die
konkurrenz von dieseln und benzinern die
batterie ist das teuerste an den
elektrisch betriebenen fahrzeugen bei
einem e smart kost zum beispiel allein
das battery system etwa sechs bis 7000
euro um energiemengen von mindestens 15
bis 30 kilowatt stunden zu erreichen die
ein auto im minimal fall benötigt werden
batterie module aus mehreren zellen
zusammengeschaltet in einer einzigen
batterie können so mehrere hundert
kleine einzelmodule stecken außerdem
bestimmt natürlich der
produktionsmaßstab den preis geeignete
lithium ionen akkus für autos kosten
heute 500 euro pro kilowattstunde
bei einer großangelegten serienfertigung
könnte man diese kostet in zukunft auf
fast ein drittel senken
auch bei diesem faktor setzt tester
jetzt an und knackte die marke von 100
dollar pro kilowattstunde
diese wird in der branche immer wieder
als der punkt definiert ab dem
elektroautos preislich mit verbrenner
mithalten können genau diese marke
hat auch general motors als ziel
definiert allerdings ohne angabe bis man
das realisiert sein soll
laut der new york times soll es vw sogar
schon gelungen sein diese marke zu
schaffen mit dem mtb dem modularen
e-antriebs baukasten einem
baukastensystem für elektroautos dass
der deutsche hersteller seit 2005 10
entwickelt teslas neuer akku soll
außerdem eine unglaubliche lebensdauer
haben aktuell gehen fachleute davon aus
dass lithium ionen batterien nach etwa
1.000 ladevorgängen ausgewechselt werden
müssen rechnet man mit einer geringeren
reichweite von 100 kilometern die
aufladung hält ein akku somit rund
100.000 kilometer teslas wunder akku
soll dagegen sage und schreibe eine
million meilen also 1,6 millionen
kilometer schaffen
das ist eine unglaubliche lebensdauer
die ihren spitznamen million miles
batterie eingebracht hat sie soll schon
ende diesen oder anfang nächsten jahres
in tester modellen verbaut werden
offenbar soll die neue batterie
technologie zuerst in china auf den
markt kommt in welchen baureihen steht
aber noch nicht fest genauso wenig ist
klar ob tesla die zellen selbst
produzieren wird oder ob sie von einem
entwicklungspartner geliefert werden
aber es ist ein deutlicher schritt von
tesla in einen neuen bereich der us
konzern will wohl in zukunft nicht nur
als elektroauto bau sondern auch als
energiekonzern wahrgenommen werden indem
er die zweit- oder parallel verwertung
der auto akkus als energiespeicher
übernimmt da spielt nämlich gewicht und
größe eine viel geringere rolle
das heißt die alten batterien könnten
auch relativ schnell aus den autos
wieder rausgenommen werden um sie
abzulehnen mit neuen batterie das wäre
mein wunschtraum jedenfalls ein bisschen
als fahrer eines tesla model s außerdem
verkündete ehemals kürzlich er wolle
schon bald keine giga factorings mehr
bauen sondern terra factories die pro
jahr eine oder mehrere terawattstunden
am batterie zellen produzieren hier
sollen neue hoch automatisierte
hochgeschwindigkeits prozesse zur
batterieherstellung eingesetzt werden
die die arbeitskosten senken und die
produktion in den tierfabriken auf ein
30 jahres der bereits riesigen giga
fabrik in nevada steigern und wenn man
sich da die batteriefertigung anguckt
ist dort schon hochgeschwindigkeit also
hoch hochgeschwindigkeit wird das in
zukunft über die tochterfirma redwood
matthäus arbeitet tesla außerdem am
recycling und der rückgewinnung der
teure metalle wie nickel kobalt und
lithium und an
genannten second life anwendung von
elektro fahrzeug batterien die dann im
netz speichersystem zum einsatz kommt
zwar gibt es noch keine einzelheiten
dazu aber tesla hatte bereits
angekündigt verbraucher und unternehmen
mit strom versorgen zu wollen
tesla bleibt also nicht nur den markt
für akkus in völlig neue dimension
sondern will auch im energiesektor
mitmischen die geplanten dimensionen
klingen zwar beinahe utopisch doch
nachdem kürzlich bekannt wurde dass
tessa seiner konkurrenz technisch um
ganze sechs jahre voraus ist scheint
auch dieser schritt des innovativen
us-konzerns durchaus möglich wir haben
übrigens schon mal vor zwei jahren über
die neuen batterien bei tesla berichtet
denn schon damals waren die daten der
neuen tesla modelle so unglaublich dass
sich da offenbar etwas ankündigt den
mars geheime batterie revolution bei
tesla anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
und zwar diesen kanal klicks zum science
and future und allen die uns hier mit
einer kanal mitgliedschaft unterstützen
tausend dank ihr seid sensationell euren
namen sind hier unten eingeblendet und
ich kann nur jeden und jede ermutigen
dabei zu sein und dafür alle videos
vorab und werbefrei zu bekommen bis dann
bleibt dran